russia has repeatedly denied that it is
targeting civilians this is as its
military continues
its advancement through ukraine our
international affairs editor dominic
wagon is in moscow and he put the
civilian deaths to the russian foreign
ministry spokesperson
maria zakharova so you're trying to
protect civilians but we've seen one
civilian building hit after another
residential blocks freedom square and
kharkiv local government buildings and
we've seen mounting numbers of civilian
casualties are your soldiers just bad at
targeting or are you actually lying
about this
if you're going to
ask a question in the same tone i'm
going i'm not going to speak to you you
can ask these questions to your british
politicians but here you
should behave
properly if you can't do this you
shouldn't be a journalist
do you understand me we are open to all
i repeat i haven't
finished my answer
i perfectly understand
because i also studied in the faculty of
international information and i know
how you should
pose questions when you want to put your
position into that i would like to point
your attention to the fact that from the
very beginning the ministry of defense
is targeting the military infrastructure
as minister lavrov
stated today it's true that
there are
victims among armed forces and among
civilians
but
it's surprising that you are asking this
question you are representative of a
country that for so many years for
decades has been waging
a bloodshed war in countries that don't
have
a common border with you
and about who is lying it's the british
government is lying
when they supported the invasion of iraq
but later they
recognized that it was it was a lie but
they were not responsible for that do
you have any questions
because it will be a pleasure for me to
answer them
multiple building in kharkiv and freedom
square is not a military target and it
was clearly hit by a missile that
destroyed the building and we've seen
any number of residential buildings
blocks of flats homes entire villages
being wiped out by russian fire i mean
what i'm saying and i you know whether
you object to my tone or not is is this
bad
aiming bad targeting by the russian
military or are you being disingenuous
with each other
there is a third option
you have mentioned two options there's
the third one these are fakes
there's some materials published by
ukrainian fighters
and when they show this materials this
is the result of what
ukrainian
fighters are doing can you give me
materials you're talking about we will
give them to the ministry of defense and
they will comment them and the way how
you are making this conversation this is
just a part of the propaganda
well the disinformation war continues um
it just gets more bizarre doesn't it
let's speak to dominic who is asking
that question uh he joins us now from
moscow um and dominic i don't think it
was so much your tone uh she was
objecting to but actually the subject
matter you're not allowed to ask about
civilian deaths uh when it comes to
russian officials
well also i think confusing with me with
a member of the british government which
i think is rather revealing about the
sort of mentality of of
people like mario zacharova and how she
views russian journalists who often kind
of mouthpieces for their own uh
government um she is a formidable
spokesperson she i think spoke for two
hours without interruption before the q
a session began but she is really the
only person you can put questions to the
only opportunity we have to hold the
russian government to account and i
think we're particularly keen to put to
her these claims that she's made that
her boss sergey lavrov the foreign
minister has made and vladimir putin
also said in this phone call that laura
was there talking about that he had with
emmanuel macron that they're not
targeting um civilians they're not um
striking civilian targets where they
clearly are from all the evidence we've
seen and
she i mean she said that i haven't seen
the pictures of this attack on freedom
square in kharkiv pictures which have
been i mean going around the world on
all kinds of news channels not on
russian official state media but that
very striking image of a missile going
into freedom square and destroying that
municipal building she says she simply
hasn't seen so we will obviously send
those pictures to her and get her
reaction but i suspect she has uh seen
them but yeah we're seeing a very a kind
of uni
parallel universe emerging between what
the rest of the world is seeing and what
russian officials have been saying uh
particularly her and her boss sergey
lavrov and his claim that the fight will
go on until russia has achieved its aims
which is neutrality of ukraine the
demilitarization of it and the
de-nazification of it as well but just
to add to what laura was saying there
well these these lines coming out of the
meeting between macro and putin i think
are probably the most depressing it is
the most depressing readout i've ever
had i've ever seen from a phone call
between
leaders because putin is clearly digging
in his heels french officials saying
there was nothing reassuring what putin
told macron putin showed his
determination to carry on operations so
whatever the international condemnation
whatever the sanctions being implemented
now and they are punishing and they're
going to really punish the russian
economy the people as well as the
government putin is carrying on
regardless